hello today we're talking about the
goblet squat so the goblet squat is a
squat variation that has a ton of unique
benefits the primary of which is
probably just that it's more convenient
in many ways than a back squat you have
more access to it for most people but it
also has a ton of benefits all its own
it can actually help to improve your
back squat and genuinely improve your
biomechanics your Mobility all that good
stuff translating to better performance
and better resilience so first you're
going to take your weight which could be
a kettle bell or a dumbbell but
literally anything really you can use a
s pot a chair a person a sandbag but
whatever the case you take your weight
in front of you hold it like this in two
hands and then just squat all the way
down and the key with the goblet squat
is to squat all the way down this is an
as to Grass Movement by
necessity you can hold the weight like
this or like this but if you hold it
like this then it's going to be easier
to you know add additional movements if
you want to it doesn't really matter
though especially obviously if you've
got a dumbbell in which case I'd
recommend holding it from one end in two
hands and as you're going down really
focus on correct form make sure that
you're keeping your back nice and
straight try and avoid your back
rounding and try and avoid any Butt Wink
this is a great opportunity to work on
those things also you don't want to be
bending over forwards the great thing
about this is that because you can move
the weight further and closer to you
that means you can move the Senter of
gravity which means you shouldn't need
to bend your whole body forwards so you
can focus on keeping a nice straight
upright torso as you get down deep into
that goblet squat so it looks a bit like
this you ideally want the elbow to be
tracking inside of the knees here that's
great for transitioning into other moves
again but it's really not the end of the
world if it doesn't so you guys know how
much I covet a deep natural body weight
squat I think this is a position
everyone should be able to get into it's
something that we traditionally have
always been able to do but it's just our
modern Lifestyles that mean that many of
us now can't this translates to poor and
impaired movement and a whole range of
different activities including the back
squat but also anytime we want to bend
over to pick something up or squat down
to play with our kids we should be able
to get into this position in fact it
should be a resting relaxing position
there's a few reasons a lot of people
struggle with this position though one
of those is ankle Mobility because your
ankles are so stiff you're not used to
dorsy flexion that means lifting them
upwards that makes it hard to get into
this position
without without tipping over happens is
that because you lack that mobility in
your ankles you can't get your center of
gravity forwards enough it needs to be
leaning back slightly throw a weight on
your back and now your center of gravity
is way back which means that if you get
anywhere near the deepest part of a
squat you're going to tip over backwards
the solution to this of course is then
to lean your body forward but this is
just a Band-Aid you're not fixing your
ankle Mobility so you still can't easily
get into that deep squat position when
you take the weight away and this is
going to prevent you from doing things
like a pistol squat because you need
that mobility in order to get down there
you'll notice any lack of Mobility the
minute you try to do a pistol squat but
if you take your kettle bell and perform
this movement it's actually going to
push you deeper into that position and
because the weight's in front of you you
can stay in this position and it's going
to act as a counterbalance so actually
AIDS that lack of Mobility helps you to
get into the correct position but also
it has a slight weighted stretch which
is actually going to improve your
ability to get there without the weight
over time so just holding this deep
squat position holding a kettle bell is
brilliant for improving your mobility in
your ankles but as well as nourishing
our posterior chain muscles it's also
really important that we nourish our
skin which is why I'm happy to have te
Hanley as today's sponsor so te hany
simplifies the process of taking care of
your skin it does this by providing all
the different products you could need
direct to your door along with an
instruction card showing you exactly how
to use them this is actually really
useful I was always a little bit
hesitant to get started with a skincare
routine just because it seemed like a
bit of a faf I didn't know where to
start te Hanley makes it so simple that
there's no reason not to and I've
genuinely noticed a really big
difference you know I'm starting to get
a little bit older now I'm 36 not long
until I'm 40 I need to try and keep up
with these younger Fitness YouTubers and
that means I can't be looking like a
piece of old leather and like I say t
hany just makes it really really easy
and you don't just have to take my word
for it teach handy have over 7,000 fstar
reviews from users around the world I
recommend you start with a level one
system that comes with all the basics a
daily face wash an exfoliating scrub an
AM moisturizer with spf2 and a PM
moisturizer and in addition to amazing
skin members of te Hanley also get tons
of benefits including at least 20% off
the retail price access to exclusive
monthly deals the ability to P or cancel
at any time and free us shipping and
because t Hanley is sponsoring today's
video they're offering my viewers a
great deal just click the first link in
the description and you'll get 30% off
your first box and a free gift don't
miss out on this amazing deal click the
link below and get started
today at the same time because it allows
you to keep your back up nice and
straight you can focus on things like
avoiding buttwink and just generally
improve your biomechanics the point
where this is like a healing movement
and if you have any problems with your
back squat then performing lots of
goblet squats is a great way to address
them and to learn how to get into that
position in a safe healthy and
mechanically advantageous manner really
simply there was a time I couldn't get
into a deep resting squat there was a
time I couldn't perform a pistol squat
without falling over backwards and there
was a time that anytime I got into a
back squat I had an awful lot more butt
weight that's far far better now than it
was a few years ago and it was the
goblet squat and it was practicing deep
body weight squats that solved that
issue for me so maybe now thinking you
know great this is a useful accessory to
the back squat and that's all but
actually the goblet squat has a bunch of
benefits all its own that make it worth
doing whoever you are it's actually
extremely functional movement of course
a goblet squat by putting the weight in
front of you is going to be similar to a
front squat and that it's going to train
the quads a little bit more than the
glutes this makes it an interesting
variation means you can build up to the
strength you need to do things like
squats if you're worried about
losing out on the glutes then of course
you can combine it with something like a
kettlebell swing that gives you the full
package and then there's what it does
for your core because by holding the
weight in front of you it completely
changes the activation of your core in
other words the weight is in front of
you so it's trying to bend you forwards
and you have to engage those posterior
chain muscles to bring yourself back up
nice and straight so again this is
training you to keep your body straight
and the reason this is so extremely
beneficial is that pretty much anytime
you pick something up in the real world
this is how you're going to pick it up
if I pick up my kids they're in front of
me if I pick up a heavy box it's in
front of me if I pick up a piece of
furniture it's in front of me but dog
whatever else I'm going to pick it up in
front of me like that and so training my
spine to handle that is actually really
useful it's going to translate to real
world strength what you don't tend to do
in the real world is put weight on your
shoulders on your back this isn't a
particularly functional exercise in that
sense it has tons of functional
carryover don't get me wrong but in
terms of whether or not you actually use
this movement out and about the goblet
squat is a much closer approximation of
how you move in the real world so this
is the Crux of my argument a little bit
if you're someone who's worried that you
need a gym in order to train to get
strong because you can't perform back
squat at home well I'm here to tell you
you don't really need to perform back
squat because you're never going to lift
that much weight onto your back because
you can't get that much weight onto your
back maybe a person in like a really
rare scenario if you're going to pick
something up it's going to be in this
position and the amount of weight you
need to be able to pick up in this
position is the equivalent of whatever
you can find to train with at the same
time there are other practical benefits
to the front squat some people really
struggle with the back squat the
biomechanics are awkward and depending
on things like lip length the
biomechanics are a little awkward
they're hard to teach for someone who's
starting out new and depending on on
things like limb lengths and torso
length and the depth of your hip sockets
you might actually find that this is a
movement you never feel really
comfortable with so rather than beating
yourself up and struggling with it and
maybe getting an injury instead move on
to the goblet squat which is a much more
natural position something that more
people can do with less trouble but I
know what some of you are going to be
thinking it's say predictable you're
going to be thinking I still can't be
training with 20 kg that's just not
enough if I'm used to back squatting
hundreds of kilograms well there are
some things we can do about that and
I'll show you how you can load it up a
bit heavier in a moment but at the same
time I just think it can be useful to
get out of that mindset a little bit
like I say unless you're a powerlifter
in which case of course you need to
practice those lift most people don't
need that much max strength you're not
going to get into that position and
perform a one rep maximum with a huge
amount of weight on your back if you can
squat 100 kgs then you're probably
golden for pretty much anything you're
going to want to do in the real world
and what's more useful than being able
to squat a really heavy weight once is
being able to move a lighter weight but
more time so you've got that strength
endurance as well if you do need to pick
something up it it's rare that you only
pick it up once you're normally going to
pick it up then walk with it or you're
going to pick up that and then get
something else you know if you're
loading pallets onto a truck or
something in the real world strength
endurance is just as important as max
strength what I really like about the
back squat in particular especially with
heavy weights is that it trains you to
be more explosive to run faster and to
jump higher and this has been
demonstrated in studies as something
that definitely happens and it's one of
the best ways to do that which is great
but it is only one way to do that and
there are other ways we can make up for
that for example goblet squat jumps do
exactly the movement we're doing here
but throw a jump in at the end it
becomes a far more explosive movement
you then want longer rest times you
going do this for a few reps and really
focus on exploding out the movement as
much as you can and again this is shown
in studies to improve jump height and
running speed so if that's what you're
concerned about then you can get that
that way and when you do something like
this you actually don't want too much
weight you want about 30% of your body
weight more than that and it slows
movement down so it's no longer
explosive you can't produce as much
explosive force so goblet squat jumps
with a slightly lighter weight something
that you can fit into your home for
example are actually perfect for this
kind of training and if you've heard
some people saying that you don't need
to train for explosiveness specifically
because you can't convert fast twitch
muscle fiber don't listen to that for
starters you can convert fast twitch
muscle fiber it's about 50% genetically
determined 50% training not only that
but we're not only converting fast
muscle fiber also training intra and
intermuscular coordination we're
training the neural drive this
contributes to our explosiveness a sort
of the myotatic stretch response so this
kind of training is perfect if
explosiveness is what you want
explosiveness core stability strength
and Mobility sounds like a recipe for an
amazing
athlete but likewise there are other
variations you can use if you want to
mix up the goblet squat a great one is
the goblet squat walk get into the lower
position and waddle along the ground
this is amazing for building strong
knees and improving Mobility but it's
also pretty intense so build up to it
slowly and don't move through pain you
can also walk with the weight in a
goblet position Squat and then continue
walking thereby combining goblet squat
with a loaded
carry or mix up all three WD squat walk
squat waddle squat walk squat I I call
this the gooble squit any locomotive
movement like this where you're moving
with the weight tends to be really good
after all that's how we tend to lift
weight in the real world we pick it up
in order to move
it finally there are ways that you can
load up the goblet squat with a bit more
weight obviously you can get kettle
bells that are heavier than 20 kg I've
got one that's 30 6 kg if you're
wondering why it's so massive that's
because it's made of vinyl and it was
cheap it's really unwieldy and was a bad
investment you can also get iron kettle
bells that go much heavier and of course
if you're using dumbbells and you go to
your gym you can find dumbbells that
weigh 50 kg that's still not a super
impressive squat but we're starting to
get to something where if you're using
higher rep ranges you're going to feel
it at least a little bit unless you're
like made of iron and of course you can
put your kettle bells your dumbbells
into the rack position hold one on each
arm and then that way you can squat like
100 kg or even more now obviously this
is going to be harder than back
squatting that much weight because
you're going to be training the core
much more and the arms this is also a
little bit of an arm workor out which
means you're going to fail probably
sooner once you get used to it now you
build some really super functional
strength that you can take out into the
real world and actually pick up really
heavy stuff so if you're saying you
don't want to lift like this because
you're not lifting as much as you would
do in the back squat it doesn't really
make sense because this is the actual
strength you would be able to use
outside of the gym so yeah if you can go
up to 100 kg goblet squat and perform
like 10 repetitions you pretty darn
strong obviously you can do front squats
if you want similar benefits targeting
the quads Moore Etc but this involves
some like arm contortion and it's a much
more technical lift if you want to train
the core even more you can load the
weight onto one side now training a bit
of anti lateral flexion or you can have
uneven weights one in each arm which is
something I do because that's the weight
I have access to I mean this is
something I literally do all the time I
lift my daughter in front of me like a
goblet squat and then she wants me to
pick something up off the ground so I
put her in one arm she weighs nearly 20
kg I squat down I pick up in the other
arm and stand back up sometimes I'm
squatting with her in one arm my son in
the other which is just a slightly
lighter version of exactly what I was
just doing over there with those two
kettle bell so yeah in terms of
specificity and transferring to real
world activities it's hard to beat the
goblet
squat so anyways guys I hope you found
this useful and interesting if you did
please leave like and share around that
helps me out immensely let me know in
the comments down below whether you
train using a goblet squat or whether
you use other squat variations and what
those
[Music]
are if you want a training program built
around ideas like this then check out my
ebook and training program super
functional training 2.0 a link will be
in the description down
below if you want more content from the
bioner then sign up as a patron you get
access to exclusive videos early videos
ad free
videos free training plans apps and all
sorts of other stuff I'm just about to
upload my fun Fun 4 routine which takes
the functional three that people seem to
respond really well to and I include the
goblet squat as one of the exercises
spoiler so yeah check that out if you
fancy it but either way guys thank you
so much for watching as always and I'll
see you next time bye for
now